I want to propose to you today
that maybe just maybe Donald Trump was
not the worst president in American
history you know when we think about
Trump and Trump's Legacy Trump was
clearly a worse president than Barack
Obama we know that that's clear Obama
Trump was clearly a worse president than
George W bush he was worse than Bill
Clinton he was worse than George H.W
bush Etc but is it possible that there
has been a worse president than Donald
Trump and I am going to suggest to you
today that that President may have been
James Buchanan what just just hear it
out okay James Buchanan was president
from 1857 to 1861. he was a pro-slavery
Democrat of course remember this was
before the realignment of the party
realignment being a Democrat then is
very different than being you know Adam
Schiff today we're talking about
something very different and Buchanan
essentially led the country to Civil War
so let's compare and contrast elements
between Trump and Buchanan and see where
we come out on race relations we might
call it you know Trump inspired and
coalesced racists of all kinds he was
extraordinary fairly racially divisive
he hesitated to condemn white supremacy
and neo-nazism until he had absolutely
no choice he passed and advocated for
policies that were discriminatory
against immigrants and minorities and he
stoked racial tensions with the rhetoric
Buchanan however
was for slavery
he was four slave holders he endorsed
the Dred Scott Decision which denied
rights to African Americans he pressured
Kansas to adopt a pro-slavery
Constitution he supported the secession
of southern states which quite literally
would have ripped the United States
apart and he did nothing to stop the
violence between the pro and
anti-slavery factions now you could say
well David you know being pro-slavery at
the time was different because fine okay
but this is James Buchanan now in terms
of legislatively and relationships to
Congress of course Trump's relationship
to Congress was a disaster clashing with
Congress ignoring defying Congressional
subpoenas and oversight requests uh
vetoing some bills overridden by
bipartisan majorities okay but when you
look at Buchanan Buchanan vetoed many
bills
completely uncontroversial bills about
land and grants and internal
improvements tariffs which at the time
were arguably necessary and
uncontroversial Buchanan tried to
actually influence Congressional
elections using intimidation you could
say well Trump did some of these things
too sure but we're saying is it possible
Buchanan was even worse now when we look
at crises that Afflicted each of these
presidencies Trump had a number of
crises uh the pandemic the associated
recession the
um rash of police brutality incidents
that led to protests in favor of racial
Justice obviously inciting an
Insurrection
comically disastrous relationships with
foreign leaders and kowtowing to
dictators all these different things
disastrous handling for sure you know
downplaying the pandemic contradicting
experts spreading misinformation uh
failing on testing and tracing and PPE
you know all these things lacking
empathy and compassion all of that but
then you say well look at the crisis
that James Buchanan dealt with James
Buchanan dealt with a situation that
quite literally led to a Civil War which
could have ended the United States as we
know it and he handled it you could say
Buchanan's handling uh of the lead up to
the Civil War was worse than Trump on
the pandemic it's a different
environment but you could say that
Buchanan said you know secession's not
illegal
uh said I have no power to stop it if
they're going to secede they're going to
secede he said it's the abolitionist's
fault those who want to end slavery are
provoking the South accusing the
abolitionists of treason refusing to
reinforce and resupply federal forts of
all kinds which subsequently were
attacked by Confederate forces you could
say he left he you could say he left
Union forces uh unprotected which is
unbelievably disgusting and he also did
nothing to stop violence in a bunch of
different a bunch of different states so
could the argument be made that Buchanan
was actually the worst president when
you think about the Legacy yeah Trump
was impeached twice and he incited the
Insurrection and failed on covid all of
those things Buchanan quite literally
left a broken nation and I don't say
that metaphor he left a nation in Civil
War which was trying to break itself
apart so I think that it's really
difficult to compare
1861 to 2021 because there are so many
fundamental structural differences that
the country saw during that period of
time of course but I think you could
make the case if you wanted
that Buchanan was a worse president than
Donald Trump betraying his oath of
office and his country and his people
which Trump did too but maybe Buchanan
did it in an even more egregious way let
me know what you think worst Presidents
in history Trump Buchanan someone else
let me know in a comment let us know in
an email we're going to take a very
quick break and be back after this all
of the stuff we've been talking about
today you can find it on our YouTube
channel on our tick tock on our
Instagram it's almost too easy to find
it quite frankly